[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud and do not give a [__]
is the Tony Michaels podcast real and
raw political and social commentary the
freedom to oppress the rights of other
people is not Liberty you [__] eating
[__] ah the smell of freedom of speech
this is the Tony Michaels podcast and
this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] them
[Music]
the ranch covidians gatherer in Waco
Texas for the 30th anniversary of a cult
leader
killing his followers
this is the symbolism that they thought
was going to be a good symbolism
for the Trump cult they're like yeah
we're gonna go with that not only that
is when Donald Trump's on stage
holding his hand over his heart for his
stupid [__] song that he sang with a
bunch of traitors who are in prison for
being traitors we're gonna play the
January 6 Insurrection on the screen
behind us because we're proud of that
[__]
we've come a long way we've come a long
way and I I know it feels like again I
know it feels like this
is bad and it is a horrible [__] it's
horrible symbolism like it is absolutely
horrible they don't understand it they
don't understand how history is going to
look back on these fools
and say wow what the [__] was wrong with
them in that in that time and space
because I guess there's several hundred
people that showed up for this rally not
even half the the venue uh it was on a
Tarmac because he can't rent an actual
venue so the the the the the Sheep fence
that they put up it wasn't even half
full not even close couldn't even fill
the seats they wouldn't even let them
bring chairs in to this event because
they had enough Empty Chairs already I
literally on the [__] list of [__]
you can't bring in is a chair
because they don't want you to bring in
empty chairs they got enough of those
bastards
in the in the on the tarmac where he was
puking up his [__] fascist vial
this is all good for democracy though
folks what happened this weekend in Waco
now there are a few things I will say
that didn't happen that I predicted I
thought he was really going to go after
Ron DeSantis but he pushed out he
totally [__] he totally [__]
wimped out on Ron DeSantis I'm gonna
explain that a little bit
uh because I want to tell you what I
think is happening politically uh to
Donald Trump and Ron DeSantis
and what Donald Trump is trying to do
versus what he does do on true social
right so I'm gonna explain that the
politics of it
but the symbolism here is [__]
absolutely bizarre that they thought
this is exactly what they wanted Waco
baby the 30th anniversary
of David koresh murdering and killing
his followers
that's what a cult leader which the the
Branch Davidians not the ranch covidians
from this weekend but the Branch
Davidians
they're predecessors in the in the world
of cult
they were devoted thought he was Jesus
thought there was no one else he was
infallible does it sound familiar
does it sound familiar
I mean you can see on our thumbnail for
this broadcast there was a flag that
they were flying Trump or death
at Waco for the 30th anniversary of the
Branch Davidians being barbecued by
David koresh because he didn't want them
to get out he he was a [__] crazy
loon he's a lunatic David koresh is a
lunatic so is Donald Trump they're
[__] crazy lunatics they make crazy
it's it's if you go back there there's a
goddamn uh documentary right now on
Netflix and there's a hundred
documentaries out there on Waco some of
them are all [__] some of them are
all [__] [__] and we're not gonna
debate I'm not gonna debate you on who
is the blame for Waco 30 years ago look
David koresh there there is hard [__]
evidence in David koresh barbecued his
[__] followers
it's just there you you cannot like it
or like it or whatever you can say
government this government that whatever
you want
the fact remains he got his followers
[__] killed but the parallels between
the two I mean
when when David koresh was in all this
trouble and he was held up in the
compound of the Branch Davidians in Waco
he was making videos and pumping out
videos to his supporters and to the
prosecutors just like Donald Trump has
been doing from Mar-A-Lago
it's it's [__] insane it's [__]
insane but you know this is the [__]
crazy timeline that we're in and these
Republicans are out there cheering this
crazy ass [__] like this is gonna win
them something I mean Jesus Christ Dan
Patrick the lieutenant governor got on
stage and said there were no drag shows
when Trump was President you are a dumb
you dumb [__]
are you are you serious this is the
[__] this is the stupid [__] we're
gonna go with because what he's saying
what Dan Patrick is saying he's telling
a lie of course you're that or you just
didn't go look I I don't know that there
was drag shows for [__] decades and
decades and decades before Donald Trump
even thought of becoming Jesus Christ
there's a video of Rudy Giuliani in drag
or Donald Trump [__] motorboats Rudy
giuliani's tits in the [__] video you
dumb [__]
who is who in the [__] takes Dan Patrick
seriously in Texas who in the what the
hell is going on down there
anyways
The Narrative is is that there was no
drag queens before Trump
forget about rude Paul and the the
[__] the
the ratings and prize-winning show that
RuPaul does
oh my God
but the narrative is is that there will
be no drag shows when Donald Trump
becomes president that's the narrative
it's the Nazi narrative that's the Nazi
narrative the other Nazi narrative is
that somehow Alvin Bragg is a criminal
and he's a George Soros
puppet and Marjorie Taylor green said it
and and I know what Marjorie Taylor
green is saying when she says that Alvin
Bragg is a Soros back prosecutor
they mean a Jew with a hard R don't get
it don't get it twisted I'm telling you
that's what they're saying the same
thing when they say this woke [__] I had
an argument
and I I do stay strong in an argument
with some stupid [__] right-wing
[__] that I the same right-wing
[__] that I've been arguing with in
these Twitter spaces Mario lets us in
these Twitter spaces of his now uh you
know I I think Mario kind of swings in
their Direction but he lets us in and
lets us speak but they got really
[__] pissed off really because they
were talking about deep State this and
deep state that and what's the Deep
State how the Deep state is and blah
blah blah and then they got on the word
woke they started talking about the word
woke and what woke means and what it is
and why it's bad blah blah blah yeah
it's really [__] dumb
but they need to continue this narrative
it is it is hurting them badly on Fox
news this morning on Fox News they're
saying oh man I wouldn't have went to
Waco and did what he did I wouldn't been
posting a picture of me with a ball bat
threatening the prosecutor that's about
to indict me that's not very good
but they're continuing to do it but the
imagery is great so I was in this space
and they were talking about wokismness
wokeism that deep State this deep state
that
I piped in of course they didn't like
when I bite they never liked when I pipe
in they just don't like my [__] style
they don't like how I say [__] and the
reason why is because it really
threatens them I mean the moment I
started speaking some dumb [__] tried to
get over top of me I told him literally
these words shut the [__] up
they didn't like that either that I used
the word [__]
but in the conversation if you want to
call it that I was trying to tell these
[__] something they weren't
listening in the conversation we were
having I brought up the Republican Nazis
that went to Wadsworth Ohio to protest a
drag queen show
and they got oh they got really [__]
upset you calling us Nazis and blah blah
blah they I mean Nazi triggered them
like a [__]
triggered them like you won't believe
lost their [__] minds you can't call
me a Nazi and blah blah and Nazis this
and Nazis that they really went off
I'm telling you folks we have the
strength of our messaging all we have to
do is lean into that [__]
they're running scared they're terrified
terrified
that the Republican party is leading
them down a road
that is going to cause them to be on the
side of Nazis we see it every [__]
day here on the Tony Michaels podcast I
show you what do you think the whole
George Soros bot prosecutor is
they're calling Alvin Bragg a Jew
I don't know I don't know how I'll say
it
and and really they're calling him a g
with a hard Arc because Alvin Bragg is
black
speaking Alvin Bragg
an obstruction uh it appears that James
Comer
and Jim I don't report sex crimes Jordan
are gonna get bent over and spanked by
Alvin Bragg now
Jim Jordan and Jim Coomer the two Jim
Bobs
there in Congress
they're trying to stop Alvin Bragg's
local investigation into Donald Trump
and Jim Comer made the claim over the
weekend that somehow it's a federal
investigation you dumb [__] it
is a crime that happened in Manhattan
and it is under the jurisdiction of the
state and Alvin Bragg you stupid [__]
and really Alvin Bragg tweeted out
um this weekend in response to Jim I
don't report sex crimes Jordan tweeted
directly tweeted him and said hey stay
the [__] out of it man and really if
Donald Trump has contacted these members
of Congress and they're acting on his
Accord don't you think that that should
be considered obstruction I don't know
maybe Alvin Bragg should start
investigating some of these members of
Congress that are helping Donald Trump
obstruct this investigation in the
Manhattan DA's office with the grand
jury having the evidence and it sounds
like we have a new witness today my
guess is is that's why we've been
delayed we've been delayed with this
indictment with the jury voting the
grand jury voting on the charges because
of a new witness now we're being told
that this witness is not Stormy Daniels
it's not Michael going we're not really
sure who this is at this point I don't
think that's been reported at this at
this juncture we know there is a new
witness that is going to appear before
the grand jury in the Manhattan D.A case
of the of the fraud to use to cover up
the hush money payment
and probably more than likely the
[__] obstruction of the investigation
that's what I would guess maybe maybe
just maybe I'm just surmising here I
don't have any evidence of this but we
know Donald Trump we can surmise all we
want he's not hard to predict he's
predictably unpredictable
is it possible
is it possible that this Witness
has been tampered with at some degree in
this investigation maybe that's what
they're going to testify to I don't know
but it's not out in the realm of
possibility with Donald Trump as he
appears to be using Congress Jim Jordan
and Jim Coomer
the Jim Bobs to try to obstruct the
investigation using official
Congressional jurisdiction over local
prosecutions which is not a thing that
exists
it's really [__] dumb it's stupid
it's stupid ass [__]
and I mean you don't have to go far with
this logic you just you just think about
it for a second the president United
States can't pardon someone who is
charged with it and convicted of a state
crime
just like a governor can't pardon
someone who's convicted and charged with
a federal crime they don't have that
jurisdiction you dumb sons of [__]
Jesus Christ how in the [__] are these
people in Congress
this idiocracy is getting out of [__]
control but we must use it to our
advantage in messaging and leaning into
engaging in our democracy and I'm going
to show you some clips from the wackos
and Waco the ranch covidians um this
over the weekend that is really going to
get people to Second think
Shredder they should vote for Trump now
this is all good
uh it appears that Ron desantis's window
has opened back up just a hair
just to hear through this
it appears
now rather he actually enters this race
or not we don't know I I don't think
he's got much of a shot
as soon as he gets in Donald Trump's
gonna burn him down but I think what
Donald Trump was trying to do with Ron
DeSantis on stage was not attack him or
not unattended not not attack him what
he was doing was judging his crowd in
the moment because he knows those are
his cultiest of the culty of the cult
right these people are the crazies of
the crazy they're the most devoted to
him who came to Waco the you know the
500 600 people that showed up there
in Waco
to [__] worship Him
at the altar of stupidity now
he was floating exactly how they would
react in a crowd to him knocking on to
santus that is what he was judging he
knows what happens on fraud social
he's already floated this on fried fish
see this is one thing that a lot of
people understand about Donald Trump
is that he views every little thing as
different every room is different every
crowd is different and he molds himself
to every single crowd
the crowd on front social he can say
whatever the [__] he wants he can post a
picture of him threatening Alvin Bragg
with a baseball bat they don't give a
[__] he can call Rhonda Santos a
pedophile on there call him pudding
meatball Ron they don't get they don't
give a [__] over there they cheer it
that's why they're there in the first
place at his cult rallies at his Nazi
rallies that he has and he wasn't too
sure last night how that would play so
he's testing it out he's testing his
material this is what a performer does
they test their material
so he was doing it
and so we watched over the weekend as
Donald Trump defiled America by standing
on stage holding his hand over his heart
praising the traitors the
insurrectionist on January 6 while
playing the footage of it in the
background they're proud of it now folks
they're proud of it
how well do you think this is going to
play with average Americans do you think
that's gonna go okay
do you think do you think normal average
Americans really believe that it was
just a tour of the Capitol do you think
that do you really think average
Americans believe that Donald Trump had
the election stolen away from him
because of suitcases and mules get the
[__] out of here with that nonsense
most America doesn't even pay attention
to this [__]
most Americans don't even know where the
president or vice president is nor do
they care and I said this yesterday in
the space because folks the plot line is
slipping away from them
and as they dig deeper and deeper and
deeper into more details on their racism
and their bigotry trying to gather up
their most staunched supporters I mean
Jesus Christ they're they're they're
almost laying aside woke and CRT for Dei
do you know what Dei stands for let me
tell you what Dei stands for diversity
equity and inclusion
that's gonna be the new Boogeyman enemy
diversity
equity and inclusion do you think
they're going to convince the majority
of Americans that that is the Boogeyman
those three words
think about this
think about it now they're gonna try to
redefine it because what they want to
redefine Dei as is Reverse Racism
just like they when they say woke they
mean black people black culture black
society
hard R that's what they mean when they
say woke I've been telling you this and
saying it
the same thing when they say deep State
and cabal and George Soros they mean
Jews
that's what they mean
it's not hard to get to the code
language
but Dei is going to be their new enemy
do you think that's going to be a
winning message for them when we get out
there and be like whoa what diversity
that's bad Equity inclusion are you
[__] [__] me this is bad stuff I
mean your grandpa's gonna be like oh
yeah we don't want participation
trophies okay the Trump the Trump Maga
cult is the king of participation
trophies
Jesus Christ he lost my three million
votes in the popular vote in 2016.
and he got the participation trophy of
being president of the United States
he lost by eight [__] million Joe
Biden didn't get 81 million votes in
2020 there's a shitload of that 81
million that voted against Donald Trump
and it was a hell of a lot more than 8
million
and he still wants his participation
trophy Jesus Christ his supporters over
the weekend were talking the microphones
saying we want him installed we don't
want to wait till the election we want
our dictator installed
they've lost their minds their marbles
have packed their [__] and left
listen if we're standing around trying
to figure out how we're going to save
the Trump cult we are done we can't save
these people we cannot
there's no turning back for these
[__] I was talking to these
crazy Kooks into space
one in particular one in particular he
used to work for Thomas Massey's
Congressional staff [__] he was
the one that got upset when I when I
said that Nazi showed up in Wadsworth
Ohio to protest drag shows and he's like
oh yeah we're I'm not against trans
people listen drag queens aren't trans
people
necessarily you stupid [__]
it's a performance it's a they're
dressed up in costumes to perform just
like your [__] orange Mussolini Jesus
who got into his Trump drag over the
weekend to spew his treasonous vile on
stage in Waco
but they don't understand they won't
understand trust me they're not gonna
get it they won't they can't
it won't happen but what we have to do
because remember those Americans that I
were talking about earlier that don't
give two flying [__] about woke don't
give two flying [__] about the words
deep State listen these people are
working two [__] jobs trying to get
their kids in daycare trying to pay for
[__] daycare get their kids to
[__] school trying to conjure up
enough [__] money that they can go on
a movie on the weekends where they don't
have to [__] sacrifice part of their
grocery grocery list that week you
stupid bastards they're not worried
about woke they're not worried about
deep State they aren't worried about it
trust me the majority Americans don't
give a [__]
we do we we listen to this [__] all day
we pay attention to politics they're not
doing it but they're gonna vote and they
can vote and that's what we have to
understand
that's what we [__] have to
understand and we gotta understand what
works
and we cannot let up we can't let up on
this they're not going to they won't
stop they're coming after your [__]
consent parents this parental right [__]
it ain't about your rights it's about
their right to take your parenting
consent away from you
when they're banning books
you're Banning books so I can't let my
[__] kid read a book
other parents don't you don't have to
let your [__] kids read a book but I
want to let my kids read a certain book
have a certain education be [__] I
don't know
use use their own brains logical
thinking rational thought
to decipher what's real and what's not I
mean that's part of the problem is
education in this country but they're
trying to strip it away from you your
health care they don't want you to have
it Jesus Christ they voted against 35
insulin for crying out loud they stopped
the entirety of America having 35
insulin they limited it to Medicare and
Medicaid
Republicans the same Republicans who who
the supporters of not the Nazi
supporters showed up in Wadsworth
the protest at drag show
it's same [__] man same ones
same
there's a Nazi
at a table eating dinner
and 10 people are sitting with that Nazi
having dinner yucking it up telling
jokes having a good time there's 11
Nazis at that [__] table that's just
how it is and that is how we win this
that's how we win this they got pissed
off in this space I mean they were
really [__] upset I mean I'm gonna
talk to it I'm gonna have Gabe Sanchez
explain it too
because he was listening in
um because I I don't give I didn't think
I gave a [__] in the space no I don't
care what they think I don't care what
they say it's the truth Nazis Republican
Nazis showed up in Wadsworth
Ohio to protest a drag show
Nazis all over the place are showing up
to protest at these drag shows Nazis I'm
not not using
they're carrying Nazi Flags folks
they're dressed up in Nazi costumes
folks
they're at the front door
they're coming for your [__] they're
coming for your democracy just just like
in Israel now in Israel today that the
breaking news is is that Benjamin
Netanyahu is tuck-tailed and run on his
judicial reforms to try to
spiral Israel into a fascist state
he is unsuccessful and the reason why
the reason why is because the people got
out in the streets
the people got out in the streets
and we and they engaged in their in
their [__] democracy and we must
engage in ours
you think they're gonna stop
you think this [__] is just gonna go
away
have you seen some of the [__] these
people post have you seen some of the
vile [__] these people say
I'm telling you they're not gonna quit
and we must not either
we have to stand and fight
for our democracy and we must engage in
it now until the 2024 election and
Beyond it is super important that we be
the Defenders
of our Republic here
because they're not going to quit if
they're [__] playing if Trump is
holding his hand over his heart saying
the Pledge of Allegiance and playing the
Insurrection in the background the one
where they wanted to overthrow our vote
overthrow our government rip up and [__]
on our constitution
and make him dictator and King
come on man
come on you're telling me that they're
not here and they're not a threat
give me a [__] break
it's time
now is the time we must not waste it not
one conversation not one one opportunity
for messaging not one opportunity for
our narrative because the American
people will get it
we just have to be louder than them and
I am only one microphone here on the
Tony Michaels podcast you are thousands
of microphones thousands
so use your microphone the way you can
the way I use mine
maybe a little different but you can do
it
talk about it tell people
I'm telling you when you when you when
you bring up those Nazis in Wadsworth
that route protesting the drag show
they get [__] pissed
they get pissed I'm I'm not you're
calling me I'm not a Nazi well listen
you may be saying you're not a Nazi
but you're on the side of the Nazis on
this very important issue where you're
trying to legislate people out of
existence
so it seems like it seems like you're a
Nazi remember the whole you sitting at a
table with them eating dinner with them
yeah that's kind of what this is
so don't let them get away with it don't
let them get away with it even if they
don't know the issues even if they don't
understand
trust me there are plenty of Americans
out there that are ready
to vote against this stuff again
they were with us in 2020 they will be
with us in 24. we just hacked to shake
the bush that is what we have to do and
that is what I do two hours every single
weekday Monday through Friday noon
Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific on YouTube
Twitter and twitch right now if you're
on YouTube on the Tony Michaels podcast
don't forget to subscribe it's free
it's free God damn it hit the Subscribe
button also like and share this damn
thing follow us over on Twitter at Tony
Michaels pod
we're uh we're coming up on the bonehead
Madness there's a new bracket over there
you can vote on it so go to at Tony
Michaels pod on Twitter vote for
bonehead Madness over there who you want
to be the bonehead Champion also
download every single episode on Apple's
Spotify and Google just download it on
all those you know what that helps us
out just saying even if you listen to it
here on YouTube I'm saying if you
listening on YouTube go download it
on the directories it helps us out it's
free too [__] them now if you're on
Facebook or still have a Facebook
account at the Tony Michaels if you're
on Midas Touch Facebook page right now
why the hell haven't you followed me
over on Facebook at the Tony Michaels
that link to my page is right at the top
there go follow me also uh subscribe to
the up wires YouTube channel the
upwire.com you can find the link to the
YouTube channel there also if you want
to link your Amazon Prime account to
Twitch I get a few bucks of bezos's
money
and it didn't cost you a thing if you
have an Amazon Prime account if you can
hear me and you have an Amazon Prime
again if you link it to Twitch you get
one free subscription
on Twitch and you can give us the Tony
Michaels podcast at subscription and we
get a little bit of money from Amazon it
doesn't cost you a thing it's a it's a
way to monetarily support the show here
without costing you any extra kind of
cool I don't know I I if you need to
figure out how it works just just Google
it or go to YouTube and type in link my
Amazon Prime account to Twitch that's
all you gotta do it it'll show you it's
real [__] easy a lot of people have
done it a lot I think we have almost 100
uh people that give us their
subscription also I want to thank
everyone who showed up last night to the
patreon Sunday rant Gabe Sanchez joined
me last night that that video is public
by the way
um we did it we were gonna we were gonna
stream the rally on Saturday but then we
decided against it because I was like
how many people I mean I didn't even
want to watch that [__] puke
into the microphone for 90 minutes doing
his same old whining right same old [__]
different diaper
so I decided that yesterday during the
Sunday rant I would invite Gabe we did
an extra long episode
of the Sunday rant on patreon I opened
it up to everybody it was invite your
friends Sunday rant so everyone got to
join it was really cool it was really
fun yesterday so I want to thank
everyone who joined us
and if you didn't watch that video just
subscribe to the YouTube channel here
it's there
the thumbnail says Wacko and Waco it's
the Sunday rant um so go check that out
if you can it's like an hour and a half
long we did almost an hour or over an
hour and a half I think
um and we we broke down uh some tiny
Clips down today we're gonna break down
some more Clips
um from the rally but we're also going
to break down some clips over the
weekend on uh the news of Alan Bragg and
some of these [__] seditious bastards
in Congress that are trying to use their
congressional power to obstruct this
investigation in Manhattan weaponize the
federal government is what they're doing
seems like projection to me doesn't it
to you
[__] idiots okay so go check that out
go check out the patreon video that we
did last night now Gabe Sanchez joined
me and thank you to all the new members
that joined last night um during the
broadcast there was we had handfuls uh
join the patreon page if you want to
check that out just go to just go to the
Tony michaels.com uh click the patreon
link or go to patreon.com
Tony Michaels you can check out my
patreon page it's a good way to support
me since I'm doing this for a living and
um you know this is what I do for my job
and we got it we gotta pay the bills pay
the electric the internet you know keep
this [__] going so like check out
patreon.commichaels everyone stick
around we'll be right back
the shitless Roundup we had a lot of
[__] to round up today right after this
we'll be right back Mark
60 seconds this is the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product part in blanket I've got
you covered part in blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard and blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardons not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome welcome back to the show thanks
for sticking around doing great
I like that [__] video wherever
you're at right now like it if you
haven't liked it already like you're
listening to my voice
you're on Facebook you're on YouTube
you're on Twitch throw some [__] in the
chat we got the best chat in the world
did you know that the best chant in the
world
I gotta slow that [__] down so the
moderators can keep up that's how many
people we get in the chat that's how
engaged it is you guys are the most
engaged audience I think out there
did you know I think we passed 15 000
subscribers I also want to thank you for
that we passed 15
000 we're on our way to 20. thank you so
much for all the support that means a
lot to us that you guys not only come
here and engage every day but it's
growing slowly but surely but we'll get
there now so our next goal is 20 000. so
if you can do me a favor share the
channel see if you can get some someone
to subscribe maybe they'll listen maybe
they'll get in the chat maybe they'll
re-watch on a replay of the video
because that's the other thing is we've
had thousands and thousands tens of
thousands of new replays every single
week of the show here
um I think it's because
um I bring the heat they're really
pissed off yesterday in that Twitter
space they were like you need to calm
down [__] are you kidding me no
I'm not I'm not gonna I'm not that's not
something I'm gonna do
and then that one of them was pimping my
show which I appreciate yeah in the in
the in the Twitter space
um he said oh we well we know we know
that all you're using is for is so that
you can go on your show and talk about
it and you can talk about us
get over it you [__] fascist
snowflake
you know what they're mad at here's what
they're mad about
no one else says this [__] like I say it
no one not on the left you go [__]
find it go go out there you show it to
me show it to me who day in and day out
comes here for two hours every day
and gets gets the extra up puts the heat
on and burns these [__] to the
ground go show it to me I dare you now I
know you you guys got some of your
favorites Hal does a great job
Richard ogetta does a great job and
there's several others out there that
that do it they just don't do it like I
do it and they're not going dude I
understand that it's hard to
get us pissed off and heated as I am I
get it I understand I'm it's it's a lot
of work to keep up this energy but I'm
energetic about it and this is just me
this is literally the way I talk about
these subjects
and that's why they're mad they're mad
in the Twitter spaces because there's
someone out there saying the [__] that
I'm saying how I'm saying it they don't
like that it's a threat
he it this guy in there and it's it used
to be a Stamper for Thomas Massey you
know Thomas Massey and [__] shitbox
who posed he's a congressman he's a
chewing on her he's an insurrectionist
and
he posed in front of his Christmas tree
with all his family with all their big
guns you know all that little dick
energy there in that picture a Christmas
photo of his family looks like the
yolkaida the American Taliban what the
[__] are they doing in a Christmas
picture with guns what the hell does
Christmas or Jesus have to do with guns
not a goddamn thing not a [__] thing
but they don't care because they're
fascist he got really upset when I
brought up Nazis he really got pissed
when I called them Republican Nazis
really [__] pissed oh man
I mean he got triggered as [__]
but that's that's the re the reason why
is because they're Nazis
I don't what do you want me to do
what do you want me to do
it you are you are pushing legislation
that is causing Nazis to go to drag
shows
and to protest them with Nazi Flags
saying really hateful bigoted [__] Nazi
[__] into megaphones what do you want
from me what am I supposed to do what am
I supposed to do and he really got mad
Gabe Sanchez he got pissed I mean
pissed when I said the word Nazi in this
Twitter space I mean he was just [__]
our boy Jim yeah he gets so so sensitive
you know what's funny is um Jim Comer's
an [__] right I mean yeah total
[__] yeah yeah Jim George Jim I
report sex right Jim Cramer is an
[__] and then this gym guy in the
spaces Jesus laugh what's his name fart
Jim flat flap flat Jewel
Flappers slappers Flappy Jim Flappy
there in the Twitter's face he they
don't like um the other guy doc yeah
they don't like us did you know he's a
chiropractor oh really shut up I I went
to I I went to see if he's actually a
lawyer right because he claims to be a
[__] lawyer but then he's a lawyer
and a chiropractor that that's a little
weird isn't it
which people is he unsuccessful in was
he unsuccessful as a chiropractor then
went to go practice law or was he a
lawyer that was unsuccessful and then he
went to go adjust people's backs but
then he had the lawyer aspect to be like
look if I hurt you
here's an NDA before I crack your back I
I don't I don't I don't know exactly I
don't know if like he invites him in his
law office and then once he gives him
legal advice they get a free crack and
you know we saw this yeah he's like look
I'll adjust your legal issues and your
back right exactly maybe that's the cell
I I don't know I don't know but anytime
anytime we talk they don't like us I
mean like Doc
they there was one uh oh yeah the woman
who came in the [__] moms of Liberty
or whatever mothers of Liberty the one
who was coming and spewing all the
nonsense about Sierra oh yeah the books
social emotional learning but then
couldn't prove that actual books were in
the classroom on the curriculum because
people have here look I'll say this
because I'm gonna go into this you know
what was that on uh on Lauren bobert
because she wants to abolish education
and they want to say it's parental
rights and parents have the rights to
decide this and that parents have always
had those rights those things have never
never never been something that you
cannot uh be a part of right however
it's the parents that could could uh
could not be bothered to show up to a
parent-teacher conference or not respond
to a to a teacher's email to say hey
this is how your student or how your
child is performing in the class here's
the curriculum we send it to you ahead
of time so they make sure to get things
ready get the books this this that
but those parents go to the school board
meetings and then [__] whine and
complain and yell and then you find out
that all of it is just a big untruth
right it's not real at all
uh and that's what those guys do in that
space all the time especially that woman
yesterday well somebody somebody called
her an expert yesterday but I wanna I
Wanna Stop get and we're gonna come back
we're gonna go speaking of schools
there's a shooting in Nashville
Tennessee in the last hour I believe it
looks like it's being reported this is
the Metro it sounds like the shooter is
now yeah you're right here's the uh has
now been is now dead yeah it's an actor
shooter event has taken place at
Covenant School Covenant Presbyterian
Church on Burton Hills Drive the shooter
was engaged by mmpd
and is dead student
reunification with parents is at the
Woodmont Baptist Church so they're
they're showing the scene here it looks
it sounds like there's four dead uh plus
the shooter including the shooter yeah
including that's that's four including
or I thought it was I thought it was
three three people and then the shooter
was the fourth let me find this report
uh they were reporting that's that one
let's see if I can I think it's I think
it's four plus the shooter and I'm not
sure you know again I don't know
um that's the parents trying to reunite
with the kids
um so that's that's that
um
yeah he is dead do we have how many uh
are pronounced Deadpool teaches priest
I'm just reading a thing here it says at
least four dead according to early
reports the shooter has been killed so
it could be five maybe four people
including is the is uh here I'll pull up
the Tweet here hang on a second let me
let me put this is from Peyton Kennedy
it looks like she's
um with the local news agency there in
um the area let's see
pull it up here uh let's see yeah she's
with good morning Nashville
um here is Peyton Kennedy she says
officers are telling us at least four
dead including shooter are dead
at the school and we're on the scene
here's footage uh from the ambulances
going by so I mean again we don't so it
looks like it's three plus the shooter I
think yeah is what we've got now this is
uh just this is just a Monday in America
folks right under but play that I sent
you a video that I think is pretty
appropriate right now okay
[Music]
um
this is from Ron DeSantis okay so this
is this morning this is this morning
yeah this is him talking about uh open
carry right yeah so okay
um so Aaron root bar has this uh if you
notice here we're gonna we're gonna hear
about guns from Tiny D here uh that
[__] limp dick piece of [__] uh he
does look look what's on the podium
education Freedom hmm and he's gonna
talk about [__] concealed carry here
why while there's a gun in Nashville
ripping through people's bodies at a
school so let's let's see what Ronnie
Ronnie tiny D has to say about guns and
education I'm sure it's in [__]
enlightening yeah now in terms of the um
uh the the Constitutional carry I mean
I'm for everything I've said that from
the beginning what the [__] does that
mean I'm for everything I don't know
these [__] see that's the thing
that pisses me off in this space too is
they do platitudes like this like Yeah
I'm I'm for I'm for everything whatever
whatever you want and whatever you think
I'm for that because I want you to elect
me and then I'll I'll do my little
fashion thing inside the government like
what the [__] does that even mean you're
for everything dude if you were for
everything then you would let people
live their own lives you wouldn't have
to feel like you had to kick down
someone's door and say are you gay right
or or you would be for all the reform
sensible reform like background checks
and making sure that [__] lunatics
don't get weapons of war I mean that
sort of thing if you're for everything
what the [__] does that mean Okay let's
listen and um but if they send me
something that is 90 or 80 I mean I'm
gonna take that win and we come back for
more at some time in the future yes sir
so there it is and that's on
constitutional care he's taking
questions there in an education Freedom
conference right which means the exact
opposite it means the opposite when
they're doing these things when they're
like oh we're we're trying to we're
trying to remove porno from libraries
they're Banning books even even in the
space you were talking about that
[__] stupid ass that was talking
about from moms of Liberty or whatever
there was she was talking about I don't
like when you use the word ban because
it's bad for my narrative I don't like
that word I'm wondering what we are
doing is removing the books
you're Banning it look just because you
banned a book doesn't mean like it was
banned everywhere that school or that
place specifically you had it removed
which means at that place it was banned
they have a very hard time understanding
when they're like oh man well it's not
banned it was just like it was just like
temp it was just like we didn't we don't
want it to be there anymore okay so then
you removed it right completely no it's
not it's everywhere it hasn't removed it
but you removed it from the specific
location so you're telling me that it
was banned right and like well it's not
no it's not banned because you Democrats
you liberals use band as a bad thing
yeah because that's what you're doing
it's you know what you know you know
what you should do Gabe we should tell
them that we don't want to ban guns we
just want to remove guns from our
country we just want to remove them that
way that way they're not in a danger or
two I don't know [__] kindergartners
this this school apparently
this school is a Pre-K to sixth grade
school this is not this is not a high
school these are little children that
are in this that are in this school
right they got shot up and just just
over an hour ago but you're telling me I
mean I don't know are you telling me
that this what looks like uh uh you know
press Covenant School associated with
the Covenant Presbyterian Church which
would then show that it's a private
religious school yeah shouldn't they be
able to I mean you know they always I
thought thoughts and prayers right what
happened to Jesus protecting it you know
the logic of the right saying that oh
you know everything happens for a reason
and God knows exactly what happens if
that is true then you're telling me now
your pro-life stance is gonna say you
know what God wanted those children to
die [__] you man [__] you every single
Republican who wants to push this idea
of like thoughts and prayers are gonna
heal this thoughts on prayers thoughts
and prayers are going to fix this
problem no it's not thoughts and prayers
don't do [__] every time there's a
[__] shooting
all Republicans do is say you know what
we gave it a good show we gave it a good
try guys we'll get him on the next one
thoughts and prayers thoughts and
prayers here's a screenshot from
Tennessee holler of course we know
Tennessee hollers on the um on the news
there all over Tennessee this being in
Nashville
um this is a a screenshot from what
looks like a local broadcast there it
says uh breaking news three kids three
children are dead so it looks like
whoever the shooter was killed
uh three children so ma'am and I just
got to point out Don Cobin here
[__] me dude [__] you [__] you you come
in here and you want to say oh oh no
Gabe's being so mean because he's being
mean to the Republican Party who doesn't
do [__] when it comes to actual
regulation and ensuring safety of
children at schools you can't go to a
[__] school a grocery store a church
a community center you can't go to a
synagogue you can't go anywhere Don so
tell me tell me why you say [__] you
because you feel upset that I [__]
called out your party for the [__]
and the lack of responsibility that your
party takes no Don you can go [__]
yourself because that's the problem your
party sending thoughts and prayers and
doing nothing nothing you look at
[__] Texas multiple school shootings
over the years you look at what happened
in in [__] Uvalde all right you look
at what happened in Uvalde and you had
people like Ted Cruz within that same
week going to speak at the NRA
convention okay being paid to speak days
after a mass school shooting where
children were slaughtered
and then you say [__] you Gabe no Don
[__] you how about you own up to your
own party's lack of responsibility and
accountability and do something
I'm sorry that you feel so upset about
it but how about you do something Don
well I mean Gabe Sanchez listen the
threat to children
they're at the Presbyterian Covenant
School is definitely drag shows it's
obvious this morning that it's drag
shows I mean oh yeah clearly clearly
clearly clearly it's the books in the
library that's literally those are the
real three children right the three
children died this morning at the
Covenant Presbyterian Covenant School
and and a lot of people are going to be
like Tony God damn how you how dare you
politicize this only an hour Hey listen
we are either going to politicize this
and [__] win or we're not right up to
you it's up to you to stand on the
sidelines go oh my God you can't say
that [__] I can't I got a microphone
and I'll [__] say it just like they
were trying to shut me up last night I'm
not gonna shut up I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna stay silent on this [__] listen if
you want to [__] win the politics of
this politicize the ever loving [__] out
of it and it wasn't drag it wasn't a
drag show that killed those three
children this morning it's not the
[__] books in the library that you
[__] don't like because it has
an lgbtq character in it that is not
what is killing these [__] children
you pieces of [__] garbage so get
over your [__] stuff your religion
straight up your [__] ass you can
believe your religion all day long and
have it and and it'd be great fantastic
but in the Presbyterian School the
religion didn't protect him not from
drag queens not from porno books but
from Guns a [__] gun that killed
three children you [__]
so get off your ass pluck your head out
of it and then realize that yeah we do
have to politicize the ever loving [__]
out of this and you know what
there's something so don Coben he's like
I'm getting on your skin yeah this is
something that gets under my skin
because I've seen it happen year after
year after year and having a more
frequency every single year and the fact
that you're like oh getting on your skin
why wouldn't it get under my skin why
wouldn't it get under my skin when I
know people
who have been associated with multiple
shootings right they're family members
they're classmates right they're cousins
who were at Michigan State
it gets under my skin because we don't
do anything about it we have we live in
a world right now where every school
shooting there is less than six degrees
of separation with a victim or someone
who has who has been traumatized by that
shooting because they were there at that
campus at that church at that grocery
store at that Community Center wherever
they were at the parade my dad had a
business that was a half a block down
from the Highland Park shooting in
Chicago Illinois so yeah Don it gets
[__] under my [__] skin so you can
go [__] yourself and when you say stuff
like who's the president let me find
that [__] comment right here because
here let me laugh I'm gonna pull this
one up of his while while we're while
you're finding that one he says people
like you covered it's not she's division
listen I I am not on the side of Nazis I
do not I do not want to regulate [__]
drag shows or prevent them from
performing you [__] idiot I don't
want to legislate certain people out of
existing in this country because I have
their sexual orientation or not or I'm
scared of their genitalia whatever it is
that you're [__] afraid of done but
listen I'm calling you Republican Nazis
because you [__] are you're with them
dumb [__] you're standing with
them you're with them you're at the
table eating with Nazis which makes you
a mother [__] Nazi done pluck your
head out of your ass you're you're not
you you don't think you're with them but
you're with them buddy and they're with
you and they love you they [__] love
you man they love that you're in the
comments here [__] with us but what
they don't know and what you don't know
is we will pounce back buddy and we are
why am I I with this [__] microphone
I'm gonna push the narrative in the
messaging and make sure every
[__] in this country is
embarrassed to have an R after their
name because they might be associated
with [__] Nazis my friend like you
that's right Don like you [__]
so when I see Don also make comments oh
sorry yeah when he says stuff like
what's Joe doing to stop these killings
well I would say that considering the
fact that back in the middle of this
month he signed an executive order to
help limit the gun violence in this
country through background checks and
other procedures to actually prevent
this right what did Donald Trump do what
did Donald Trump do nothing nothing so
if we want to compare two people your
presidential campaign candidate or
whatever [__] you want to call it
whether with Ron DeSantis who wants to
deregulate gun restrictions in protocols
to ensure the safety of their
constituents or American citizens
go [__] yourself because here's the
thing when you compare the two people
the current President Joe Biden actually
doing something to sign an executive
order versus Donald Trump who says oh
you know what we should give more money
to people to have babies I don't know
maybe that's because white people are
are losing the percentage of the total
population in this country or maybe
because it's white people are dying from
mass shootings either one
when you look at the two candidates
Donald Trump Ron DeSantis and and Joe
Biden for the next election I'm going to
go with Joe Biden because he's actually
doing something to ensure safety he's
actually pushing forward legislation and
actually ensuring measures so that we
don't have more of this right but since
then or rather since any time before
that right after after 90 was it 94
which was the
assault ban right I think is what it was
1992 1992 right and then once that went
out of effect right then we saw a an
increase in shootings we saw an increase
in in gun manufacturing and Don asked is
it working it did work it it did work
yeah [__] idiot the lack the lack of
of intelligence out of dawn right now is
very telling right well he's got he's
got a buddy in the chat he's got a buddy
calls me a commie oh man all right see
this is the funniest part see this is
the funny part because they call they
call me a communist which hey hey Alex
yeah sure I am but what do you go what
the [__] are you what are you gonna do
about it what are you gonna do about see
this this is the thing when when I went
in that space and I said the word Nazi
you could tell who were Nazi
sympathizers in the space because they
got really [__] angry right that I
said I mean even I didn't call anyone
exactly in the space and Nazi I just
said there were Nazis that showed up in
Wadsworth Ohio that protested a drag
show and that they thought that meant
that I was calling them Nazi that's what
they thought it meant right and that's
on them and I said that I said that's a
you [__] problem when you get butt
hurt because you're with the Nazis on
these issues and you're mad that I'm
that that I get to frame it up that
you're with the Nazis because you are
you're on the same side as them that's
not that's not a meat problem that's a
[__] you problem just like Alex here
it's like he he points out fentanyl
deaths are ten to one right now Kami and
I I think he's he's calling me a
communist I think he's winning yeah yeah
I think he's which is kind of funny it's
kind of funny that he would call me a
Kami because I mean he clearly doesn't
watch the show enough
but I mean Alex keep watching maybe
you'll figure out if I'm a communist or
not or maybe go look up the word maybe
go look up the word communist go look
that word up and see if you can figure
out what it means and then come back
here watch every day two full hours from
front to back man come watch and then
see if I fit that description and that
that would be interesting if you could
do that where's your passion for the 108
000 dead Americans I've got a lot of
passion for fentanyl I actually believe
that um the Republicans have proved
proven proven that Joe Biden under his
administration that there's been more
fentanyl Marjorie Taylor green actually
said it in a congressional hearing on
the record that Joe Biden has has seized
Mort fentanyl at the border than than
the Trump administration had so I mean
I'm very confident in a in an
Administration that is competent
that you know isn't [__] taking
issues seriously that are killing
Americans like I don't know fit and all
deaths and [__] gun violence that
don't leave American people hung out to
dry because they want to get score
political points and they want to gain
power
stupid [__] okay Alex
I'll wear them it's just so or my red
bed so stupid [__] so dumb so dumb right
like Don Cobin Don Coben and his buddy
Alex the fact that they want to use
you think Don is actually Jim maybe he's
just hiding oh maybe it's Jim you know
maybe it's fake Gabe who knows could be
it could be
but when I see people like Don like I
feel there's a part of me that feels
kind of sad
or rather
it's
it's like I feel embarrassed you know
for how pathetic the attempt at like
owning the libs is by saying that you
know for things like You're he's getting
under my skin again yeah because it hits
[__] home dude it hits so close to
home for me so that's why I'm upset
that's why it gets under my skin for the
fact that not only is it
is it children or loved ones or or
friends and family that are close by or
or victims of of these tragedies
so the fact that when we have Don Coben
in here who's like oh man you know man
what's gonna do here's the thing you can
you can create whatever what about is an
argument you want to say like
what's what's uh Joe Biden doing which
we know right he literally did that on
March 14th so not even less than two
weeks ago he signed an executive order
but the fact that you want to use some
what about ISM argument to get at us or
get at someone who is connected through
one of these traumatic events right one
of these shootings to say well what's
what's Joe Biden doing what did Trump do
what did Trump do during that time right
and also the fact that you're willing to
say oh well what's Joe Biden doing like
he's not doing anything about it now
okay fine if he's not doing anything
about it now then why aren't you
speaking up right why isn't this an
issue are you okay if that these deaths
are happening because it's under a
Democratic president and that's how
you're owning the Party by saying oh man
this is all Joe Biden's fault because
these guns are here and these little
kids are dying that's a terrible
argument that you're trying to make
right now if that's your attempt to own
the libs
it's pathetic it's desperate and it's
disgusting so the fact that you come in
here and you want to say oh man who's
the President Joe Biden isn't doing
anything even though he is the
counterpart is well then what did Trump
do what did Trump do during the time
that he was President where these
shootings were happening right it's not
like these shootings didn't happen at
churches or synagogues or grocery stores
or playgrounds or wherever right like
all of these
areas where a lot of people come
together the fact that you're now trying
to say well
well you know Donald Trump did it but
like what did Donald Trump do he didn't
do anything he didn't pass legislation
he didn't try to to to mitigate this by
Inc by having a ban or doing background
checks or ensuring that gun owners have
to go through safety training and actual
uh class to learn how to handle a
firearm or or you know didn't increase
the age to 21 or whatever it might be
like he did nothing about that nothing
about that
um it's well you want to see who else
isn't doing anything let me show you
someone else who isn't doing anything uh
the senator from the state where this
happened uh Marcia Marcia Blackburn now
look at her statement here on Twitter
about the um the shooting there she says
uh Chuck and I are heartbroken to hear
about the shooting Kevin at school in
Nashville let me guess let me guess I
bet it's a prayers that she's going to
offer she says my office is in contact
with federal state and local officials
and we stand ready to this why is she
with Federal assist or federal officials
I thought that I thought I thought they
were the Deep State and they're against
they're they need to be
um I thought they were bad the federal
officials why are they very good
question why is she there [__] weird
okay but she says at the end thank you
to all the First Responders working on
site please join us in prayers hey do
more than prayers [__] yeah do more I
I'm sure I'm sure I'm sure the parents
at the Covenant School of those three
children that are [__] dead because
the guns aren't excited about you
talking about your [__] prayers right
I'm sure they would have liked if you
would have joined in on what the
American people actually want and it's
[__] reform on guns to make sure
lunatics don't get their weapons don't
get weapons and be able to go into
[__] schools and murder children you
dumb [__] [__] it's I'm sick I'm just
sick of this [__] and you know I I love
I love in in the comments we've got a
lot of new trolls and we must have
picked a lot of these people up from hey
Tony can you tell me if Tennessee is a
permitless carry state I I would almost
bet it has some of the some of the least
gun restrictions in the country well as
of July 1st 2021 an adult can carry a
handgun openly or concealed in Tennessee
without a permit without a person is
yeah if the person is 21 or older or 18
or older for certain military members
Tennessee does not require a permit to
carry a firearm whether openly or
concealed
than the rights and the lives and the
and the health and the well-being of
children right well I [__] those kids
right [__] those kids you know guys
the wild west but you know there was
more gun regulation in the Wild West in
some of these states than there is now
it's kind of funny well it's here's
again we've got a lot of trolls here so
I want to point another one out Joe is
destroying the economy laugh my ass off
but listen listen I I'm looking at the
stock market right now dude and it's up
214 man and and everyone all the right
Wingers are focused on oh crypto's
falling and the banks are failing yeah
because they suck and they need shitty
[__] bets you dumb [__] wait
wait wait hold on but after 2008
what happened in one in 2008 there was a
bit of a bit of a failure that happened
financially in this country wow I
remember it I remember it yeah yeah
Global failure that happened it was kind
of an event right but didn't we pass
legislation what happened in 2018 wow
see you can't you can't be regulating
things that need regulated see uh if you
regulate things that need to be
regulated you might regulate them who is
the president that deregulated banking
protections no that's um it's probably
probably
um is the guy who lost by three million
votes in the Bible in 2016 oh and then
lost by almost 8 million votes right and
yeah he was ass spanked Yeah by Joe
Biden by sleepy Joe in the basement
which is going to happen again by the
way I just wanted to make sure you know
hey Don who was the President right well
here's the thing I I I want to stay on
this topic but we really do I want to
get to the news of the Manhattan D.A I
want to get to a few clips of the rally
I do want to talk about that but we had
this news pop-up this morning so I
didn't want to ignore that so um stick
around we're gonna we're gonna go to a
break when we come back we'll go to
Alvin Bragg's statement to Jim Jordan
directly he direct he he quote tweeted
him on Twitter and he's like hey [__]
better not obstruct that's probably not
a good idea I'm gonna show it to you
when we come right back don't go
anywhere we'll be right back right after
this break
what the [__] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
letters from the trucker Convoy
there's Tammy by the time we reach DC
White was 50 strong in number so
Patriots ran out of gas along the way
we got plenty of Slam gems install
near run out of Natty light
hope it don't rain tomorrow so we can
Circle the city again
here's Bob
dear Bob I'm fixing to send you some
more of them Doritos you like the red
bag not the live love and blue one
in your absence I discovered a rash on
my neck and no it ain't no hickey and I
even seen my cousin Brody in ages
stay strong wipe your ass at least once
a day years tame me
we're back to the Tony Michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome back to the show wipe your ass
at least once today
[Music]
I mean people wipe their ass down and
wake up
it's [__] weird we're gonna get to
some of these clips we're gonna get to
some of these clips someone uh brings up
a good point here about where this
happened this happened in Nashville
Tennessee and someone brings up the
point here
um they banned they banned drag shows in
Tennessee and how how many did it kill I
can't find that comment back you guys
are
whoo you guys comment a lot here nope
that's not it either holy [__] here's
here's the thing I mean we do know that
we do know that uh shootings have been
have been uh stopped
not not by the police but by actual drag
show performers right right I if I ever
have a kid I would most definitely Trust
my kid with a drag reformer with the
Dragonborn over any Republican yeah any
Republican Republican this is okay in an
instance like this Republicans would be
the one who [__] push the kid down or
throw the kid at the shooter to be like
no no no like to protect themselves
right right that's how alpha Republicans
are in a real shooting they won't
actually be the good guy with the gun
they won't even [__] move the gun
they'll be so [__] in the moment of
when a shooting happens right
the decision making that you're trying
to have right there the the the the
adrenaline that's pumping the fact that
you've got to make the Split Second
decision you're not trained in that
scenario you do not know how to go about
it for you don't know how good the other
you know the shooter is the person who's
coming in but the fact is like those
people in a split second I guarantee you
that good guy with a gun would never
ever be able to actually make the right
decision right or have the gun or use
the gun
because they're so afraid right and
again I really do believe that
Republicans in that moment would be the
ones to throw a kid or throw another
person in the direction and be like ah
[__] it and then they run away right
well that's literally that's literally
what they're doing when they're
legislating certain people out of
existence in their state but they can't
[__] protect children in a school
come on man yeah so that's literally
what they're doing they're throwing the
bodies of the children in front of the
gun okay um so I want to move on to the
Alvin Bragg situation did we get any
news on who the witness is yet or we
just know that there's another witness
that has appeared before the grand jury
we don't know it's not Cohen it's not
Stormy Daniels right it's not someone
that uh from what I understand it's also
not someone that uh has already appeared
that his his attorneys Trump's attorneys
have the cause
of the prosecution so so they're so
they're corroborating evidence it sounds
like this may have been why they were
stalling and delaying last week yeah I
mean who knows maybe it's someone
because of you know maybe maybe it's a
it honestly could be a recent action
that Trump took in terms of trying to do
again I'm saying I keep saying
[__] manga idiots out there listen
there is obstruction here and and it is
clear as day and Alvin Bragg here is his
tweet this is Alvin Bragg from the
Manhattan DA's
um official Twitter account now he's
responding to Jim Jordan here Jim Jordan
said our response to Manhattan D.A Alvin
Bragg now Jim Jordan is the chairman of
the Judiciary Committee I can't even
believe I have to [__] say that out
loud that's [__] nuts that that
[__] [__] box is a chairman of
anything really at this point the signs
of [__] jail cell because he wouldn't
report sex crimes talking about [__]
saving children [__] Jim I don't
report sex crimes Jordan
um but he basically in their statement
to the Manhattan D.A Jim Jordan and Jim
Comer are like we're going to
investigate the investigators because
you don't have jurisdiction I'm going to
show you what they mean and this I'm not
making this [__] up Jim Comer went on
[__] CNN yesterday can you pull that
clip for me yeah um with Jake Tapper
where he's talking about how he um is a
federal [__] investigation so they're
trying to make it a federal
investigation in Congress which is not a
thing Congress can't do criminal
investigations we know that from last
year all last year when the January
select committee can only make criminal
referrals they can't do criminal
investigations I mean they can collect
evidence and if they see crime they can
make a referral but that's it
so here's Alvin Bragg's statement
um and and he's he's much more
diplomatic than I am I I don't know it's
almost like he's a prosecutor or
something and I'm just a [__] guy
with a microphone he yells and screams
all the time I don't know maybe that's
just the case Alvin Bragg says we
evaluate cases in our jurisdiction based
on the facts the law and the evidence
now he's really [__] smacking down
Jim Jordan here yeah it is not
appropriate for Congress to interfere
with pending local investigations he
says not appropriate for Congress to
interfere
that is one step closer to obstruction
there's interfering and there's
obstruction and they're getting really
close to it he's giving it he's like
look I'm gonna let you off with a
warning right now right you take another
step and foul like you're out of the
game dude as interference can be
obstruction obstruction is illegal he
says this unprecedented inquiry I can't
even believe he has to say this
unprecedented inquiry by federal elected
officials into an ongoing matter serves
only to hinder disrupt and undermine the
legitimate work of our dedicated
prosecutors which is obstruction at some
point and I believe it can be
obstruction if Donald Trump [__]
ordered Jim Jordan and Jim Comer to do
this if he coordinated with them to put
out this statement from the Judiciary
Committee officially it is [__]
obstruction I don't give a [__] what
anyone says it's obstruction and and
Alvin Bragg knows that it's possible
that it's obstruction he's saying it you
know he's thin bailing in here I'm
saying that out loud that it's [__]
obstruction right now when Bragg is
being a little more diplomatic about it
here uh he said he continues on he says
as always we will continue to follow the
facts and be guided by the rule of law
in everything we do it feels like to me
Gabe sancheza this is Alan Brad going
hey [__] hey [__] yeah I will I will
bend you over my knee and I will spank
your bare ass Jim Jordan I mean he's
that's I mean he's he's you know he's
publicly he's like look you guys wanted
to make this a public show that's
totally fine you want to get into my
lane and tell me what to do I mean Hardy
makes a good point what the [__]
happened to state rights why are they so
full of [__] they're all they're only
made of shoes
right Roe v Wade there was supposed to
be a states rights issue right and then
after it was overturned
and they started seeing that people were
like hey actually I want this protection
in place right you you see that during
the midterms as we're leaning into their
uh though that's what was happening
and then you see people like Lindsey
Graham and others being like you know
what we need a national band so a
federal like I thought you guys said
that it was up to the states right
and it's just something I mean like
Wyoming got them I think it was Wyoming
uh or Utah got themselves in a bit of a
pickle because they in order to like own
the libs and come after Obama after the
American Health Care Act they put a
provision in their state constitution
that said basically adults have the
consent to make their own medical
decisions about their own bodies and
then when they tried to introduce this
ban on abortions
even the judges were like you guys made
this part of your Constitution you guys
literally [__] up by trying to own
them and put this in there and now you
told them in the State Constitution that
as an as as a as a as an adult or
whoever you can make the decisions about
your body bodily autonomy and now it's
coming back to bite them specifically in
the ass which is hilarious but that's
what it is it's never a states rights
issue what regardless of the topic it's
always we want to say it's states rights
and then when the states decide against
what our minority voice is speaking then
we have to then bring it to a national
federal level because
we got butt hurt that our plan backfired
right well listen to this there's no
better example of this this [__]
states rights and then not states rights
then this interview here with James
Comer James Q Anon Comer right who is
the [__] chairman of the oversight
committee I can't even believe I have to
[__] say that [__] that this crazy
bastard
it who doesn't understand State
investigations and federal
investigations
um and then we'll talk about it but
let's listen to this idiot and break
down his
maganomics here yeah it should be done
by the Department of Justice on the
federal level well he's investigating as
I understand it uh potential violations
of State crimes
uh even at that look let's let's
yeah but but but but but no she see that
the thing is is that that doesn't help
my narrative that fact that you're
throwing out there really puts a jam in
what I want to say so basically here's
here's here and again this is the road I
I believe because everyone keeps saying
this even on the left keeps saying oh
these charges out of the Manhattan DA's
office these are the least amount of
charges I think that's all [__]
Donald Trump is freaking the [__] out
about these charges in the Manhattan
DA's office I don't believe it's because
he thinks he's going to be indicted or
he thinks they're weak charges I believe
he knows what he did yeah yeah he knows
what he did well let's [__]
knows that they're gonna find out what
he did and they're gonna charge him with
felonies and he ain't gonna be able to
run away from that [__] it just ain't
gonna happen uh the so one thing I I was
somebody confirmed in the in the chat it
was Wyoming like I originally thought
but I said Utah as well but yeah Wyoming
was the one where they basically were
like yeah you it states rights you guys
put it up there uh but also Hardy had
been like what had happened was like
that is exactly what comes to mind Jim
Comer starts talking he's like okay look
look I know we said States right stuff
right but this is different right and
you see that in this Jake Tapper because
this is this is Trump's right this is
well this is see this is
this hurts us it happened on a Tuesday
and it was supposed to happen on
Thursday but it was actually Tuesday
Thursday would have been states rights
Tuesday it's it's better again they both
start with T I see how that can get
confusing but it was Tuesday versus
Thursday that's how it is I'm Jim Comer
and I'll see you later this is why this
is why Manga is getting confused and
this is why they're losing the plot line
and this is why they're going to be very
disappointed when Alan van Bragg does
bring his [__] charges against Trump
the reason why is they're so focused on
the [__] check that was written to
Stormy Daniels that that Michael Cohen
went to prison for federal prison for
you [__] boneheads who you you think
you think that this [__] career
criminal Donald Trump stopped criming
after he made the [__] payments to
Michael Cohen to cover up the [__]
hush money and besides the way that he
did the payment doesn't exclude it from
state law you boneheads it's because
you're he's he claimed it right I mean
he was writing it off as it legal
expenses you [__] idiots it just
doesn't make any sense when you look at
it through a lens of I don't know
reality and what's real but but the fact
remains is that if you think Donald
Trump has stopped committing crime
around this issue you're not paying
attention Alvin Bragg had to basically
get out a switch and spank Jim Jordan
and this idiot James Comer's ass to tell
them don't obstruct you [__] morons
I'll come after you do not obstruct do
not do not take orders he's like look I
could come after I could Alvin Bragg uh
you know I think is it was just it's a
smart move to be like look stay in your
lane don't [__] enter my
investigation because here's the thing
at the end of the day you're on a
federal level this is a State Crime
we're investigating it's a business
business crime there's a lot going on
here uh and also you don't know [__]
about what we have right you don't know
[__] about [__] everything yeah dude
everything they have you see it people
talk about Twitter spaces you see you
see Talking Heads look Tony and I do not
know what Alvin Bragg has okay it could
be less than what we think it could be
more than what we think right and the
thing is nobody [__] knows but
whatever it is there's a big enough case
for Alvin BRAC to then go from a closed
situation to reopen this right now so
there must be something here and again
nobody knows and the only people who
actually know would be the jury who is
privy to that information and the
prosecution who is bringing a case but
everyone who comes is in like uh Bob
Costello and other people who go in to
give their their testimony they don't
know they only know to the questions
they're asked and the evidence that is
presented before them to either
corroborate or uh refute right and
that's what it is and at the end of the
day nobody knows except the people that
are working on it so people on the left
people on the left you keep saying this
is the weakest one they shouldn't I
don't think they should bring this one I
think it should be Jack Smith like look
Jack Smith's gonna do his work okay and
I know you're [__] upset at Merit
Garden I've watched a lot of people be
upset at Merrick Garland like look Jack
Smith is doing his work Bonnie Willis
and George is doing her work and Alvin
Bragg is certainly doing his
um so just I I know I know it's it it's
gonna be a long time but it's obvious
this morning if they have a new witness
in front of the grand jury that is
probably the reason why they delayed not
because they're not going to indict him
in the Manhattan more it's more likely
that they're going to indict him to
delay the vote Alvin Bragg is going to
bring a vote to the grand jury on these
charges
it just so happens that there was more
evidence that he needed to present so he
delayed it
um but let's let's round it up here and
see how Jim Comer tells us this is a
federal it's not a state issue and he
should be obstructing an Alvin Bragg's
investigation let's listen let's just be
honest here I mean this is about
let's be honest oh man
let's be honest here okay what I'm going
to tell you is a lie so right let's be
honest let's let's let's hear the lie
that James Comer is projecting the
presidential candidate when you look at
what we believe the role of the
Manhattan D.A should be is to fight
crime I mean that's one of the biggest
issues in New York we saw that in the
midterm elections last night okay so
he's saying a couple different things
here he says Donald Trump is a
presidential candidate he is not that is
he is not he's not on a ballot anywhere
he's not on a [__] ballot he doesn't
have petitions for about there's not a
ballot measure and besides he's not a
presidential candidate in a major party
he actually has to run against other
Republicans to get that nomination you
dumb [__] so and he's up on the
whole political thing and it is politics
it is political because it's about a
political payment that was made to make
your Stormy Daniels didn't say how
little his dick was ahead of the [__]
presidential election in 2016. almost
every investigation this [__] idiot
is in is because he he's made politics
out of [__] so spare me to politics [__]
it is politics we all realize that he's
a [__] politician
um so but the other thing too is here is
what he's saying is this is the
narrative that you keep hearing out of
the right they're like Alan bragney's
concentrate on crime they're in New York
City the crimes out of control murdered
black people black people this black
people that's what they're saying that's
what they're saying they're they're
scary black people in New York City and
Alvin Bragg needs to concentrate on that
he doesn't need Cox trade on Donald
Trump that white rich guy he's he's
harmless he the kind of crime he commits
doesn't hurt anyone okay that's what
they're saying let's continue
November uh voters overwhelmingly
rejected many Democrat candidates
because of the crime
crisis you [__] barely won
right you barely won and then your guy
your guy couldn't barely get over the
threshold to be the speaker because of
people like you you dumb son of a [__]
okay keep keep going Jim keep digging a
hole here see here's the thing and I I
said this in the space yesterday is that
when these Nazis these Republican Nazis
are digging their political grave do not
do not take the shovel out of their hand
that's why I appreciate all these people
in that space talking all kinds of crazy
loony ass [__] because most Americans
don't believe that garbage and wouldn't
believe that garbage they know the
[__] truth they're not stupid I mean
they may not know politics they may not
know Civics but they're not dumb they
know the teachers in elementary schools
aren't teaching children how to give
blow jobs as she claimed in that space
yeah that's what they were claiming
claim they were claiming that
Republicans have never never been for
mail-in bounce you're full of it it's
like a [__] the guy in there last night
who was the GOP chairman of Florida uh
was like
well at one point he was like I'm pretty
sure Ron DeSantis wrote his own speech
I'm pretty sure Ron DeSantis wrote his
own book I highly doubt it yeah
you think it is he said that yeah that's
what he said and if you I mean that was
just one thing that he said but in
addition he was also a person who came
after me he's like oh I don't know who
this Gabe guy is yeah
this woke because what I said in the
space last night and goes to this whole
conversation that Republicans have which
is
they've jumped the woke shark right
everything's woke gas stoves washers
books Banks Air it's all woke everything
and so when they asked me last night
they were like hey what do you think is
gonna happen I was like honestly I think
this is an issue within the Republican
party and no one on the Democratic side
is actually worried about it right right
because when we look at what you know
woke is it's like oh hey I'm empathetic
towards another group I'm you know
inclusive but also I'm understanding
there are injustices and uh uh system
like there are issues within our society
that created unfair advantage that and
yeah it's it's
just a few words woke is don't be a
[__] bigot right yeah I mean it
really is that just just don't just
don't be a [__] bigot that's pretty
simple I mean and if you're against that
well we know who you are right so yeah
well that's that's the funny part about
that space is they were going on and on
and on about the Deep state for a while
and then they got on this Oak thing as
if deep State and woke were the same
thing they were talking about it like
it's the same exact thing right and I'm
like guys most Americans average
everyday Americans don't give two
[__] shits about woke or pronouns
they don't give a [__] yours you're
you're the ones that are worried about
the word woke you are worried about what
pronouns are and what they aren't you're
the ones who are focused on this hyper
focused on this deep State woke pronouns
[__] that is what's LED you to have
Nazis protested drag shows and you're
trying to legislate people out of
existence in certain States like this is
what has led you down this road because
it is a youth thing it is a you who who
tries to make these issues and Americans
don't give a [__] just like people don't
give a [__] what James Comer lies about
but he's still gonna do it let's listen
our cities we're trying to do something
about that and the House of
Representatives and one of the reasons
we believe we have uh high crime rates
in certain parts of America is because
we have prosecutors that that are soft
on crime and we believe that our tax
dollars and that's where I come in with
the house I was like I mean we believe
tax dollars would be better spent uh
Prosecuting uh local criminals that's
what a D.A is supposed to do Donald
Trump
um see the thing is he lived in
Manhattan that's I don't know I mean the
thing is Jim Comer loses the plot the
whole way throughout right first he goes
well it's the states thing and uh we
should go in there as honestly I can't
play any more of it I can't stand it and
then he goes well it's he's like and
he's like yeah he should be focused on
crime okay well uh it would seem that
the crime happened within the
jurisdiction and the purview of the
person who's investigating Manhattan
right and then beyond he goes well you
know he should be focused on business
crimes well this is a business crime
right he's Associated himself as the
Trump organization making these payments
to Michael Cohen as a way to cover up
the the hush money payment that he made
uh to Stormy Daniels so that Melania and
others didn't know as we were weeks away
from the 2020 or the 2016 election right
so
the he's like well for his estate's
thing right he's okay we'll say okay
fine oh we should look into business
crimes well it is a business crime and
it's like dude you got to separate the
man from the business well then we got
to separate the man from the former
presidency I mean what what the [__] why
you people always are losing the plot
line here's here's a plot line in Waco
because I want to move to Waco okay
there is a there is a development on the
shooting by the way okay so so let's
come back down here in just a second I
want to move the Waco uh well what what
what's the development you got so it
looks like uh the shooter is a female
teenager okay uh the shooter was a
female and appeared to be under teens
she entered the school through a side
entrance door three children and three
adult staff members were killed so it's
not just three it's six but now it's up
to six yeah so it was seven remember was
she a member of the school
appears to have two assault from right
in Reading two assault rifles oh weapons
and a handgun it's almost like you could
um you could predict this stuff
um just like you could predict the
Criminal on stage the the criminal and
cheap on stage praising other criminals
um here is the image
from the wacko rally in Waco
um this man I'll tell you what man you
talk about
um Nazi projection holy [__]
um you don't get much more than this
this guy stand on stage with this heart
over his hand listening to this January
hey what's that yeah what's that photo
in the background there yeah well I
think it was a video they were playing a
video of the Insurrection
um so they're proud of it now they're
proud of it not only proud of he's
putting his hand over his heart remember
when he was talking about retribution I
am your retribution this is what the
[__] he's talking about he's talking
Nazi [__] now I told the audience last
week listen if you got Netflix you had
listen I know it's about an hour I think
it's an hour and a half this documentary
you have to go watch it's called Hitler
a career now the reason why you have to
watch this one specifically is because
this one was made in 1973.
and it looks through the lens of Nazi
Germany from 1973. no no history past
1973. it's very important that you go
watch that and remember when it was made
and the perspective that it was made
through that we didn't have Reagan we
didn't have Jimmy Carter we didn't have
Clinton we didn't have Obama we didn't
have trumpism in this country we didn't
have 911 we didn't have any of the gulf
Wars none of that [__] existed in this
in this perspective of Nazi Germany in
1973 it's called Hitler a career go
watch that [__] you will be like
whole it's I mean it's kind of boring
it's not really you know but it'll
[__] you'll go holy [__]
um yeah someone's saying the the shooter
was female team that's all rivals yes we
uh and it seems like the death toll is
up to six six students and six adults
sorry not six adults
18 minutes ago I'm I saw on Twitter it
said three children and three adults on
NBC right now they at least 18 minutes
ago including the shooter or not do we
know I'm
uh no well see here's here's what I'm
there's seven dead because the shooter
uh was killed I know what I'm reading as
of 18 minutes ago so I don't know if the
update on Twitter is more ahead of what
I'm seeing on NBC but 18 minutes ago it
says Hospital spoken gives an update on
the death toll we can now confirm three
children and two adults from the school
shooting were transported to our adult
emergency department three adults two
children it is not immediately clear if
the gunman is part of the five okay so
um I'm gonna lay that story aside and
we're gonna talk about that tomorrow
because we're having more developments
tomorrow yeah um uh someone point out
1977 is the documentary yeah 1977 yeah
yeah okay
it's two and a half hours yeah two and
okay well it's longer than I thought too
I've watched it several times every time
every time um I I lose track uh
especially when they start losing track
of the The Narrative when I watch the
video of the Nazis protest the um the
drag show right Wadsworth Ohio I went
and watched that documentary immediately
I know that sounds weird but again go
watch it you'll understand what I'm
saying
um so let's go back to this wacko rally
in Waco
um the the trader in Chief now here's
Fox news this morning talking about this
that picture I just showed where he's
standing with this hand over his heart
saying the Pledge of Allegiance well
he's not saying it it's playing over
that loud speaker but it has his voice
on it right it has his voice on it and
then
um with the January 6 Insurrection in
the background where they tried to steal
our government and topple our
constitution yeah here's what Fox news
is saying about it this morning this is
[__] delicious
this is such an opportunity for
Republicans just to say look at what we
did look at what he's doing look at what
we had look at what he's doing and I
think for president Trump to spend 80
percent of his time complaining about
court cases instead of just looking at
his own record and what he would have
done let me tell you what about whatever
done to SVG let me tell you what I would
have done over in um to Syria if they if
we are guys got hit uh for the 74th time
uh and twice in two days he does that or
other candidates do that they're going
to be unbelievably successful because
that's going to be the conversation of
the kitchen table instead the president
United States foreign president United
States opened up with January 6 video
which is insane he should be running
from that period I don't care his point
of view that is not a good thing for him
I thought that was absolutely awful even
though he was winning in the polls that
will not help okay so let me tell you
the politics breakdown of this this is
why Brian Gilman is very terrified of
this he's not terrified of this because
because he thinks it'll hurt Donald
Trump in the primary he knows that it
will affect him in the general election
Donald Trump
is not going to win the general election
and they're terrified that he is going
to be the nominee and he will lose big
which when he loses big now this is this
is very important for you to understand
why we as a pro-democracy coalition need
to make this happen we need to bury this
[__] in ballots now the reason
why it's so important the reason why Fox
News is terrified is because they're
going to lose the plot line When Donald
Trump ascends to the nomination of the
Republican even if he's indicted on
three different charges three different
jerseys whatever it is whatever the case
may be and he burns down every single
candidate that comes his way when he
becomes a republican nominee and faces
off a Joe Biden in general election and
he loses by almost 15 to 16 million
votes it is going to be clear in this
country that we don't want trumpism we
don't want your [__] legislating
[__] drag shows we don't want you
[__] discriminating against trans
people we don't want you [__] Banning
books we don't want you taking women's
bodily at Economy Way no none of it [__]
you we don't want your [__] Fascism
and Fox News and Republicans are
terrified of this but there's nothing
they can do to stop it this is their
problem they've created this and what we
should do is politically take advantage
of it [__] them we should politicize
every single moment every single [__]
every single image that they've done and
that's what Brian kilman is saying here
on Fox News he's saying hey hey dummies
they're gonna take advantage of this
they're going to take advantage of this
because this January 6th stuff is not
popular with the American people it is
just not
and the American people watched the
January 6th select committees and
they're going to be paying attention
when Jack Smith charges that
[__] and anyone else including
the the the prosecution or the grand
jury that's happening down in Georgia
that is possibly going to show a road
map for Michigan Arizona and
Pennsylvania and other states that
wanted fake electors
and a fake collector scheme and so Ryan
Gilman knows knows the political Fallout
that is behind this uh it with if and
when this happens that Donald Trump
continues to walk towards the nomination
then a Republican party and a huge loss
um in um in the general election I want
to show you the huge crowd that they had
down in Waco
we showed this last night on the yeah
here it is
um that is pretty small now if you want
if you if this is the fascist Pig Pen
here you can follow my mouse or the
sheep or the Sheep pen whatever you want
to call it
um you know you can see the outline of
the fencing here of how many people they
thought they were gonna have and it's
not even close yeah um now in the list
of things Gabe there was a lot of things
that you couldn't bring into this it
seemed kind of woke to be quite honest
honestly if you're gonna we went over
here Banning things from a rally right
it seems something out of it awoke AF
Playbook seems like cancel culture to me
um and let me show you that list but one
of them I thought the most significant
one and the funniest one I mean there's
some funny ones in there but I thought
the funniest one is chairs they were
like look do not bring your [__]
empty chair we got enough [__] Empty
Chairs all right look we don't know
plenty of Engineers we need standing
room only right but also we can't let it
seem like uh
less people are here right like
the fact that the fact that they had the
aerial photo is great but yeah they're
like if we had close-up shots at which
they did it was like oh empty chair
empty chair person empty chair empty
chair person person empty chair empty
chair like even in the yeah
uh this person who did this graphic
pointed out balls they couldn't bring
their candles what kind of balls but I
mean that's not difficult for them not
to play balls in this they're trumpers
right but chairs was in there I think
that's hilarious but here's here's
here's where it gets [__] woke people
you couldn't bring your [__]
e-cigarettes your explosives you can't
bring explosives or firearms and
everything what good what good is it
having in Texas if you can't you know
right throw around some M16s and then
fire your your sidearm into the air when
Trump takes the stage this is [__]
we're doing it I mean if I were down
there I'd want to shoot off a firework
to be like yeah let's go this is [__]
ridiculous you can't bring your e-cigs
your explosives or your Firearms how
woke is this rally man I want to know
the logic
cigarettes like I want to know the logic
behind e-cigarettes is the e-cigarette
like is the e-cigarette woke and they're
banning the woke thing they're like oh
man if you're gonna smoke a cigarette
you gotta smoke a real cigarette I I
don't know I guess maybe it's the whole
like is it there yeah I don't know
they're like oh we know that
e-cigarettes aren't good like I don't
know what their reasoning here is but
for whatever reason they feel triggered
by e-cigarettes enough where they're
like it's banned
they think it's gonna melt their brains
you're talking about uh brain milk
here's the guy who is uh being accused
of stolen Bauer Valor he's talking as
Christina Bob here that [__] traitor
um
this is this is wild [__] when he says
what he says and she doesn't catch on
then he's stealing Valor and then she
continues and he's trying to get her to
shut up it's it is a great exchange here
um this is this is Maga in a nutshell
watch this did you serve I did where
where did you sir Maureen me too what
was your MOS I was special oh
I bet you were I think you were you were
special I'd say you are special you're
still you haven't left special now I
want to point out when she says I was
too I was a marine he realizes oh [__]
oh [__] this is not gonna go well for me
because I'm probably not a marine and
watch him touch her arm there no let's
back it up just watch wow he touches her
arm in the moment he touched his arm
when he realizes he's screwed he says
I'm a marine and watch what she says
where'd you say Maureen me too what was
your MOS I was special oh I see okay
I flew into places yeah
where were you stationed I I
can't go into detail okay but this
interview is over
God oh what a [__] show so this is this
is the expertise that they're
interviewing in the crowd uh on Trader
TV news network uh Christina Bob at the
helm of um
all right holy [__] [__] are you
kidding me
um it just it just puts Maga in a
nutshell they're [__] Liars they know
they're [__] Liars they know they're
[__] lying they don't care that
they're lying anymore it's not about
truth I mean here's another here's
another [__] box uh Marjorie hoodfoot
green the petty Eddie here's what she
had to say about Alvin Bragg
here we have a Manhattan D.A Alvin Bragg
on the verge of breaking the law as he's
trying to please his master George Soros
and bring these charges charges against
President Trump it's unbelievable Bogan
he's not the president Alvin Bragg is
the Manhattan D.A you are a member of
Congress you cannot stop this that is
not your jurisdiction and by the way
stop calling Alvin Bragg a Jew with a
hard R okay stop doing it we all see
what you're doing and and actually you
know what don't stop doing it because
really frankly and this is what I said
in the space yeah I hope you guys
continue this nonsense because it only
makes average Americans go you people
are the [__] crazies why do you think
Carrie Lake didn't win in Arizona she's
a [__] nut job she's a goddamn
lunatic she's nuttier than [__]
squirrel turds and continues to be
nuttier in Squirrel turds you think
Carrie lake is going to get any kind of
[__] elected office anywhere in this
country especially Arizona the crazy
[__] that she's doing telling Arizona
you didn't do what you what what you
think you did you voted me and not her
she's claiming now the Democrats voted
for her get the [__] out of here with
that [__] [__] you Carrie Lake this
is more of the crazy and let me tell you
as they lean into the crazy we should
lean into pointing out that they're
[__] nuts and I'm telling you it's
gonna work it's gonna work folks it's
gonna work if we just engage in this
stuff and let Americans who don't
typically follow this stuff know that
yeah they're out of their [__] minds
another example of how they display
their minds is they let the news on
stage
why in the [__] would you let this guy
on stage anywhere where you're trying to
I don't know have some kind of coherence
in your campaign this is a campaign
route campaign rally if you think that
Ted Nugent is the person that you're
like you know what you know who I'm
gonna bring up to really get this ground
going right hey Nugent like that's like
it's that's not the person that you want
to really kick things off with really
right I mean like because I guess also
this rally even though he had done other
rallies before this I guess this Rally
or I guess it really is a rally but they
said this is the kickoff rally for his
presidential campaign which again 30
years it's the first official one right
or right this is the first official
rally to kick off the campaign for his
presidential uh Journey back to come to
the White House you know he won't win
but
he goes you know what the person I
really need to get things rolling to get
this crowd going to get people excited
is Ted Nugent right or bring some order
especially yeah right I was gonna say
that save the children people are like
yeah let's get the pedo up there on
stage that'll that'll really get him
riled up what the [__] are you kidding
me but let's listen he he uses this is
hilarious I just play it and we'll
explain it
[Applause]
back I didn't authorize any money in
Ukraine to some homosexual weight weirdo
what okay so so uh apparently
um Ted Nugent is stuck in his last hit
Cat Scratch Fever from 40 years ago
because he's using words like homosexual
and he's throwing it around to people
who I don't know I don't know if
zelinski is actually a homosexual we
talked about this last night on patreon
thing he's married so I mean maybe at
the best he's he's bisexual but why why
why does it matter I mean I understand
if you have the argument I don't want
American money to go to Judy crane
because I love Putin and I want to
support dictators all around the world
like I understand that argument what the
[__] does it have to do with him being
gay or not gay what the [__] does that
have to do it doesn't have anything to
do but for everything is about sex with
these people you notice that they're
like oh the war in Ukraine that's about
sex it's all sexualizing children like
what what are you talking about you
people are way focused on people's
sexual orientation way too much if your
first argument is to go after someone's
sexual reference it shows that you don't
have a good article oh is that what it
is yeah I mean I see there's a lack of
intelligence yeah and it is the news it
is dissonance it is the news uh yeah it
is the nudge cognitive dissonance and uh
Dunning Krueger and like all of these
aspects of these Republicans are like
man I'm gonna [__] own him and like
it's here's the thing
that you don't even have to say anything
with any bit of intelligence
to get that crowd excited right you
could say man I'm gonna go [__] on my
wife later or whatever he does with this
weird she main She-Man named wife yeah
his wife's name is she Man by the way I
mean that's what I'm gonna say but the
fact that you know
like he could again he could say
anything he's like oh I'm gonna go do
this crazy obscene terrible thing and
they'd be like let's do and it's like
is there is there any thinking that goes
in like the people here they hear loud
noises and they go yeah well listen to
this this is the lieutenant governor in
Texas this is this is if these people
live in Texas and vote in Texas this is
their lieutenant governor listen to this
crazy [__] that he says and you'll be
like what listen
[Applause]
Donald Trump was president
there was no Dei or ESG or drag queen
shows with children attending
he wouldn't have put up with that for
one moment
um so there were no drag shows yeah when
uh apparently and there was no diversity
no inclusion
no equity Dei there was none of that
when um he was President are we are we
sure did did did uh and and uh
someone keeps pointing out his actual
name and his actual name is Danny with
an i Danny
Danny i e Danny i.e.m go he's just like
dude
own your [__] name man just own it
yeah
it was like oh it was Danny IE but I
changed it to Daniel or I changed it to
Danny with a Y but he's like nah we're
going with a completely different name
you know what my name's Tony right so
and I've been called Tony my entire life
yeah and it's with a Y you see it right
there it's with a Y right but every once
in a while even my grandma would put an
eye on it I would never I would actually
laugh because I'm like well obviously
and you'd be like yeah Tony Collette
yeah yeah totally but I mean I I just I
never really upset me I always laughed
because they would spell it wrong
because Tony is an easy name to spell is
it seems pretty hard Tony yeah well you
know it can be
um here is um here's a a little bit of
Donald Trump bashing DeSantis and here's
why I'm wrong I'm gonna hey remember how
I told you when I'm wrong I'll tell you
I'm bugging wrong I was wrong my
prediction of this was wrong listen to
this
I'm going to spend Wesley that was a
good speech you guys yeah yeah but
they've been very loyal but I'm a
loyalist yeah he is and yeah when a man
comes to me yes in his eyes
he said almost nothing behind the polls
and he's fighting somebody that's at 42
and he's got almost 30 million dollars
in the bank he said almost nothing he's
got no cash get to it Grandpa I can't
give you an endorsement there's no way
you can win okay do you know what he's
talking about here Gabe's hinges is he
talking about Mike Lindell no who's he
talking about he's talking about tiny D
pudding me
yes so Ryan so he's saying that Rhonda
Sanders had 30 million dollars in his
own personal no no no no what he's
saying is is that his competitor in the
governor's race because you gotta
remember Roger Santos was a congressman
a no-nothing nobody no one knew it still
isn't no nothing he's a piece of [__]
but the point is is that Ron DeSantis
came and begged Donald Trump is what he
claims here in this yeah he also claims
that he sent the FBI to help him in the
2018 election right the FBI was like we
never did that that was not a thing but
but he didn't this is what surprises me
well let's watch the clip and then I'll
yeah yeah he would surprise you me about
the clip you're dead
but he fought a little bit like 150 he
was certainly know Jim Jordan that I can
tell Jesus Christ he forwarded a little
bit just a little bit on impeachment
hoax number one impeachment hooks number
two meaning on television because I
didn't know him very well but I saw him
so he came and he really wanted I said
you can't win can you how do you can win
sir if you endorsed me I'll win please
please sir that's his invitation of
Rhonda yeah I mean either way I find
this hilarious right because either the
story is true and Rhonda Santa showed up
to Trump and begged and gobbled and
cried to get an endorsement or the
stories I want to go with that I want to
go I'm going to go with that I mean
let's go with that if I'm gonna go with
the obvious lie here that he was crying
and begging with Ted Cruz ate pudding
with three fingers
he probably cried in front of trump and
begging but even if it's not true even
if it's not true right like it's great
because now it's in the Lexicon like
it's already been entered into the race
right that Ron DeSantis is a crybaby who
begs for uh a presidential or a
gubernatorial endorsement but that's
that's the that's that's what I keep
telling everybody like look these aren't
things that we're claiming yeah is there
a report we're saying it they're right
they're saying it on themselves and
that's what we should encourage that's
what we should encourage they're going
to turn the American people off from
voting from them on their own
we just have to make sure we keep
pointing it out and showing and then let
them kill each other and attack each
other where he's claiming that Ron
desantos cried the thing that I well let
me finish the clip and then I'll I'll
say the thing I'm disappointed that
Donald Trump missed
of course
and I said all right let's give it a
shot because honestly the secretary of
agriculture the secretary of agriculture
okay so he was talking about the
Secretary of girls is going to run
against Rhonda Santos in the race but
that wasn't even the case it wasn't even
the nominee there was a primary that was
going on now the the funniest part about
this whole thing is I actually think
he's full of [__] I think Ron DeSantis
did come kiss Donald Trump's ring Donald
Trump probably doesn't remember it at
all because Donald Trump doesn't give a
[__] about anyone but himself like if
it's not about him he doesn't remember
this what he remembers is what someone's
telling him the story was like yeah he
came in your office Mr President he beg
you he was almost crying he had pudding
on his fingers that's what maybe maybe
he maybe he was told that Rhonda Santa
showed up to beg right and then the rest
of the story was just based on Don Jr
and he's like oh I've got too many
experiences with little kid kids crying
and writing with pudding on their
fingers yeah listen you think Don Jr
eats his pudding with three fingers I'm
just asking I think I think he eats it
the same way like a fascist thing where
they don't use a [__] spoon I don't
know I think I think spoons are woke man
right well uh I honestly think that he
didn't he doesn't eat it with his
fingers he's one of those people that
like sticks it into their mouth and then
just like you know right eats it I think
so well she eats it out I mean that's
what it would be right okay well you
don't you if you don't use your fingers
as a pencil maybe I should stick it and
suck it in your mouth and then because
you're done maybe I'm just eating more
pudding cups without a spoon I'm just
saying it might be good practice that's
the down junior way anyways talking
about sex and having babies making
babies uh Donald Trump babies Donald
Trump talking about making babies now
he's saying white babies when he says we
in this clip he means white folk he
means crackers is what he means he wants
cracker babies let's listen to what he
said we will support baby bonuses so
many people like baby bonuses new baby
boom that will be coming baby boom we
need babies all of this is what we need
babies
we need the baby
excuse me excuse me baby
we need the bonuses for the babies and
the Boomers oh my God you know what's
hilarious about
um this this uh narrative there because
Oliver Fox and all of these Trader news
networks are like yeah these woke
liberals they're just a bunch of single
women who don't want to have babies like
what the [__] are you talking about yeah
dude
notice how [__] obsessed you are with
other people's [__] bodies and their
uteruses and their [__] genitalia and
who they're [__] and how much they're
[__] if they're using protection
Jesus Christ will you shut the [__] up
about your [__] nonsense listen if a
woman doesn't want to get married and a
woman doesn't want to have a kid that's
her [__] business that ain't your
[__] [__] she doesn't want to have
sex with you it's that's it it sounds
like a problem yeah
and then what happens and then you get
Donald Trump is like screw me horse days
Daniels
and it's just dude look did you use a
woman's Choice she does what she wants
and because she doesn't like you that's
on you dude wait wait I'm glad you
brought up stormy
um because this is going to go off the
rally just a bit but this is great
um she's been tweeting at people who've
been commenting to her oh yeah we can
it's [__] she's good I we gotta get
her on the [__] show I know I think
the connection that we got to reach out
to Cohen I well that might be I might
have to reach out I doubt you yeah maybe
I I I've emailed her several times like
hey come on the [__] [__] I feel like
he's our connection we gotta okay he's
the one right that's I think he's the
missing link here it could be well I
think that might be but we got to get
stormy on the show so Terry Savage Terry
sa9382-47689 on Twitter
I said Niner that's a joke from last
night if you were on last night's
broadcast you know and if you're not on
last night's broadcast go watch the
video get the joke
um so Terry Savage here says why did you
sleep with him even though you knew he
had a wife here's what army replied with
why did he invite me to his room take
off his clothes and Corner me when I
came out of the bathroom even though I
knew he had a wife you [__] idiot
she's a porn star man and there was
another one where they were talking
about her getting pounded or something
and she's like yeah that's kind of what
I do for a living you [__] [__] like
there was another one where she was she
was like yeah all three inches yeah yeah
something like that oh yeah she's she's
doing a magnificent job for Humanity
over there people are like they're like
I'm just gonna volley this one up and
she's like and I'm just gonna [__]
Spike the [__] out of it right it's
[__] hilarious I mean again stormy if
you can hear me and I just I just
tweeted the thanks for that tweet maybe
she can hear me maybe she can come oh
here's the three inch one this is a
screenshot of it
um
president Trump wouldn't touch you with
the 10-foot pole true he used the three
inch one dude I don't I don't I mean
like honestly there's a part of me where
I'm like yeah Stormy could probably go
and do a whole you know probably do like
a solid five minutes on this she was on
Jimmy Kimmel and she she held her own
pretty well and she was making like off
the cuff comments and jokes that were
pretty good
um she also identified in a row of mush
orange mushrooms
uh what his the size of his mushroom was
it's pretty good if anyone hasn't seen
it just go Google uh Jimmy Kimmel's
Stormy Daniels yeah you'll come you'll
find it I think we played it on the show
before yeah here is here is um if you
want to know how Grandpa's reacting this
morning we're winding up the show we're
getting to two hours here
um it kind of goes by so [__] fast
now there's so much [__] man [__] and
then we didn't get through half the
[__] Clips we need to play but that's
just the way the cookie crumbles here on
the Tony Michaels podcast we're trying
to get the three hours Let Me Tell You
Folks if you want us to go to three
hours the one the one quickest way to
get there is to go over to our patreons
go to patreon.com the Tony Michaels or
patreon.com I am Gabe Sanchez check out
our patreon page for all the extra
content over there
um that'll get us to the three hours
faster than anything
um because this is our living and for us
to do three hours it's gonna take
probably two and a half extra hours of
prep and editing and all that kind of
good stuff to do this so it doesn't just
add an hour to the show it adds extra
work to the prep and afterwards and that
takes away from other stuff that we're
trying to do so
um if you want three hours which I know
you do and I know we could do it I mean
we could do probably five hours a day to
be quite honest yeah but you know five
hours is a little much but three hours
I'm willing to do all extra all Tony
Michaels right in your face with Gabe
Sanchez sitting here with us
um we just we just need just that little
extra bump uh so go to patreon.com
Michaels and patreon.com I am Gabe
Sanchez to help us out with that here is
here's how he's reacting this morning
holy [__] yeah I don't know who this
witness is but he seems to know election
interference through project patterns is
the New Balance stuffing for the
Democratic Party
that's what he's yelling I I don't know
how else to do it I mean it's one of the
I mean there's a few I said in a tweet
and I was like says the guy who made at
least thrown three phone calls to
Georgia election officials
2007 yeah to find 11 780 votes and also
to the same comment that Raskin made to
Lauren bobert Republicans have this
tendency to use Democrat when they
should be using democratic right well I
said Democratic I said it correctly
because that's my instinct
um is to say it that way so there's one
other video library makes a good point
yeah when it's in all caps you know that
it's true yeah well here's the thing
that's why I keep saying liberals out
there stop saying that these charges
that the Manhattan DA's office are going
to be small and they're insignificant
they are not they don't have anything to
do with that [__] chick that was
written to Stormy Daniels it's all the
crime that happened after that
okay it's all the crime that has
happened from that payment to now to
today like it's it's right now it's um
it's two o'clock Eastern p.m Eastern and
Trump is probably still committing
crimes around this Stormy Daniels Hesh
money payment so we're we're concluding
all the obstruction up to this point now
I want to show you one more video I
thought was [__] hilarious this
morning
um and I I really think
um someone asked what do you call this
and I call that the Trump youth look
this is [__] wild [__] watch this
[Music]
[Applause]
what
day
[Applause]
[Music]
um
yo they motion for Jesus bro
oh my God some high on life Mosh Pit for
Jesus [__] what the [__] I called it the
Trump you listen this this [__] [__]
this white Christian nationalism [__] is
getting out of hand it's getting out of
hand like you said when they're doing
Jesus mosh [__] what the [__] yeah dude
oh wait wait wait wait wait cosmon says
Christ Cooks
you are the best [__] audience in the
world oh my God Christ gox this is why I
come here every day this is why I can't
do it every day because you
[__] in the chat are the
funniest son of a [__] is on Earth they
really aren't oh yeah one more thing
before we leave I want to see if you
recognize this guy from the um from the
rally I thought I saw him in the um
in the in the rally footage I don't know
if you've seen this picture yet I don't
know I don't know if you've seen this
picture yet and did you see this guy in
the rally footage it's supposed to be a
redneck alien look at this gay look at
this I mean what he looks pretty
familiar what's on the what's on the end
of the gun
[Music]
um oh no it's just boot never mind yeah
this is a boot but I mean this is a that
is that a manga hat is that look at that
look at that look at that hand just in
the [__] pants there yeah I'll tell
you something man if every redneck had
four hands this is exactly what they'd
be doing smoking a cig drinking a beer
playing with his balls holding it no no
hold on hold on but there were no balls
allowed at the rally well that's true
and no cigs and no alcoholic beverages
and no guns oh what this [__] is oh [__]
this is fake news fake news
oh I can't get over the Christ Cooks
thing what the [__]
um okay there's one other thing I want
to do I played it yesterday before we
left the um the patreon broadcast but I
want to play it again today
um about the wits since we're talking
about the Waco rally Tennessee Brando
he's a country music artist and I
actually got a hold of him
um and I I got a hold of him so it
sounds like maybe we'll we'll coordinate
on a project
um yeah I'm open so maybe me and
Tennessee brand to work as you guys know
I might or might not be a uh someone who
can sing country music maybe
possibly but here's Tennessee Brando's
new song about the wieners in Waco take
a listen all right here's y'all song I
wrote about Waco
[Music]
Trump went down to Waco to wave his
weiner around
the cult showed up in their pickup
trucks he made those boys proud
30 years ago Chris burned his people to
the ground
Trump went down to Waco
waved his wiener around
said Newton had a lot to say like we all
give a [__] that's all that he's good
for since he only had one head
[Music]
pillow guys
they were weaner waving in Waco
trunk legs in the air
not one truth was told that Faith No One
seemed to care
the rest of us were wandering
why he's not in jail they were winner
waving in Waco they can all go straight
to hell yeah
Trump went down to Waco the way of his
weiner around
staring at indictments and still not
backing down
I heard Stormy Daniels say there's not
much to be found
Trump went down to Waco
the wave his weiner around
yeah Trump went down the way gold the
waves little wiener around
[Music]
thank you Tennessee Brando for the great
song about Waco I'm hoping we can
coordinate something yeah Tennessee
Brando
um and hopefully maybe we can get him on
the show or something I'd like to oh
yeah if we get him on the show so and
talk about his art and hit this music I
think I think it'd make a real
difference honestly I do especially the
where he's from how he sounds the music
that he's singing um and to speak to a
lot of people especially when you make
it funny it's hilarious so I love the
song I Love the song and well maybe
we'll play it a few more times here on
the show everybody running out of time I
appreciate you sticking around with us
here on this busy busy Monday uh we'll
keep an eye on the story from Tennessee
uh from there looks like there's been an
update it's uh they've confirmed that
she's not a team but she's a 28 year old
uh woman okay so it's it's um she was a
young woman not a teen is what they're
confirming are we still at the same
number we're still at seven total with
her so three three children three adults
including this woman they're currently
investigating
um they got to the second floor saw the
shooter a female there were five member
unit what was on the second floor at the
time
um they are looking into the connection
uh as to like why she targeted that
school specifically so I'm sure there's
something there's got to be some reason
why she just showed up to that random
school or chose that random school but
she got through the side entrance
um and is a 28 year old woman
um who who is the shooter yeah it's a
damn shame so we'll stay on top of that
story we'll stay on top of the uh
whoever the witness was showed up in the
Manhattan DA's office to testify against
trump it looks like that's the case
um so we'll keep our eyes on that for
tomorrow same time same place don't
forget to subscribe to the YouTube
channel right now it's free go follow us
on Twitter at Tony Michaels pod the
bonehead Madness is going to continue
there's new brackets today you can go
vote for the brand new brackets I'm
bonehead Madness make sure you're doing
that download every single episode of
the Tony Michaels podcast on Apple
Spotify and Google and follow us on
Facebook if you still got an account
over there at the Tony Michaels also
subscribe to the up wires YouTube
channel our friends over there at upwire
subwire.com if you want to find a link
or just search the up wire on YouTube
why you're subscribing to our YouTube
channel as well thank you for 15 000 by
the way your business audience in the
[__] world the other thing I want to
tell you is make sure you're linking
your Amazon Prime account to your Twitch
account you get one free subscription
with your Amazon Prime account if you
give it to us we get a few dollars of
Jeff bezos's money we get billionaires
money [__] him so and it doesn't cost
you a thing so link your Amazon Prime
account to Twitch give us that one free
subscription it'll help us out and also
go to patreon.com
and check out my extras that I've got
over there on patreon.com go to Gabe's
page patreon.com I am Gabe Sanchez
there'll be a new video coming out today
sweet I just I released on social media
my newest clip and then I'll probably
have I'll probably have one in the next
few days on patreon
um I give you guys Early Access to
social media Clips as well so you'll get
those and then we do like the Sunday
rant like we did yesterday ask me
anything I'll probably didn't ask me
anything
um in the next few days in the next week
I'm gonna try to pick out a day that's
going to work we're gonna do a patreon
party I'll probably wait we'd be wasted
I'll probably be drunk for that party
because we're just gonna have fun we'll
talk about some stuff get drunk maybe
people get high on Edibles I don't know
we'll do what we want in that party
because it's our [__] party and it's
on patreon ain't no party like a patreon
party because patreon party don't stop
what this is what it would be so true uh
you know so everybody same time same
place tomorrow see you then Surf's Up
[__] you've been listening to
the Tony Michaels podcast in your face
commentary of current events and
political news no rules No Boundaries I
think we've made that perfectly clear we
hope you enjoyed the show and we'll be
back soon in the meantime follow toning
on social media at the Tony Michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
[__] them [__] em
[Music]
Murphy's meal Barn hadass Beacon